evan britton here coming to you live
nobody nobody
cares all anybody wants is this i'm in
your [ __ ] house right now
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah right now i'm so mean
to heaven be quiet
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing i'm evan britton
and i'm mike tyson we got a great guest
oh we have a guest yesterday
excellent guest the man the myth the
legend
excellent elky yeah david what's up alex
hello michael hello michael
i love that man you get a great voice
for radio
and a face yeah in the facebook radio i
love that faith for radio
radio so uh you know the thing
we were just having this conversation so
the thing that you woke up with this
morning
that said i am alive and the thing that
you woke up with that said i'm alive
is exactly the same thing that's
talking to you right now i agree
you know i agree absolutely we're we're
you know we're all poking out of the
same
thing saying hi to each other and our
our ancestral scars define who we are
and and
[Music]
who the [ __ ] knows well we do know we
know about
no we but we we do it do we do no we
know
what do we know we know we know nothing
exactly that's a lot
well it's too much yeah that could be
i true it already i like it already man
this is heading in the right direction
so alki give
give our listeners our our viewers a
little
uh breakdown of who you are and what you
do
well um as as simply as you can
this is some good [ __ ] it's your stuff
right here yes this is beautiful
but it's not my stuff it's it's it's the
uh
it follows it just followed me you know
the thing is it's not about who
who i am it is about what what am i yeah
right what what am i it's what is
what is my experience you know what you
know what
what what is this you know the idea
uh i i got really when i did my had my
experiences with uh
with uh 5mu dmt and uh
uh i did it for a long time i i did it
for six months
every single day so several times oh i
love this [ __ ]
several times a day and uh they won't
let me do that much
i wanted to but you know the thing is is
that it does actually continue
to heal you you do go through healing
and at some point
it does stop working and um
and and it is not the kind of thing that
you want to do
obsessively it's not the kind of thing
that you want to
smoke or or do on a regular basis
because it's too awesome
i mean for me anyway can you explain
it's stopping working um what does that
look like
uh i feel like
where you stop having
true visions of a higher
higher uh perspective of reality
when you when when you are in a state of
constant
being in a place of dissolved
awareness of self or ego or whatever
well you know whatever
um you know that once we liberate
ourselves
time everybody time stuff is coming in
it's a square square key
all right we're back again
we're back let's go brother get some
keys
you know you know you know when i was
you know i i was thinking about the 80s
yeah and driving down the road and
and how society and the world and
everything has changed i mean so you
know south korea legalizing cannabis is
crazy from beheading from beheading to
giving your license
you know from one day to the next you
know the whole
i was in the caribbean while i was in
the caribbean 70
of the nation are going to end up in
jail for cannabis
70 and they live in a majority of the
people are rastafari in this particular
place
outside of the villages they're all
restful and they all live with the
cannabis in their lives integrated into
their lives
and everybody lives on these arcane sort
of
um laws of uh that are so draconian
they're sort of
meant to keep people down and oppressed
right and that's
you know and that's part of the the the
evolution of our of our of our conscious
understanding of who we are going into
what we are and what is this experience
i'm having
what is it yeah and how can i improve it
for myself
ultimately yes and in doing that
everybody else around me
yeah i feel as though
cannabis and the rising
awareness of these plant medicines and
the toad
um are all about what's up for the keys
are you sure where's my backpack i just
look it's not in there
oh [ __ ] no keys is it in the car
it might be in the car i might have just
left in the car just start the car
that happened to me i need to do that to
listen one day put your foot on the
brake and press start i went out
partying one day evan right i'm in dc i
went out partying
in the club take the bag take the bag in
the car with you take the bag in the car
with you and start the car
there you go i'm partying dc i go up in
the club party i come out my rolls royce
is missing no why could i let the key in
the [ __ ] car i'm so [ __ ] high
that's the key in the car it's better
than leaving it in
magic mountain and forgetting [ __ ] have
you ever done that
walk into a car park which is empty at
the beginning of the day then you go
back and it's now filled with cars and
you don't know where you left your car
oh [ __ ] and that was in the days before
we had car alarms
i'm that old wow right that was a
[ __ ] of a situation
well some kids losing your car and uh oh
that's six flags
i always leave the club i couldn't find
that one
yeah you know that evan when i was
younger
i couldn't find a class they [ __ ] that
[ __ ] car you just go buy another one
i was younger i [ __ ] was reckless
so i look at you have you considered
ibogaine
say it again eyeball gain what is that
well i began i i began
plant medicine it it is it's the bark of
an african tree called the oboga tree
tell me about that and it's it's like
like five meow dmt it's the the there
are the two most powerful compounds
known to man is a fibromyalgia which is
five methoxy dimethyltryptamine
yeah and then there's ibogaine which is
an extract from the iboga plant it's the
what kind of trip does it put you on
it's a three-day vomit show
oh i'm not in yeah i know i know me
neither believe me
but but but but some people have no
experience whatsoever i had the full
disney effect
um and and i saw myself
and different incantations of me or my
ancestors
uh and and i tell you i'm i'm a really
very very strange looking person
in my in my in my previous lives yeah i
wouldn't even want to begin to tell you
but but but now tell me i want to know i
want to know
sex is a construct tell me can't stuck
in what form
gender is a construct not sex not the
act yeah
um uh but you know for me the greatest
part of all of my experiences with this
was um
seeing the very worst in mankind seeing
feels you know limitless feels of death
and destruction and in it being the most
beautiful thing at the same time
in the sense that beyond what matters
in our in things that we're attached to
you know beyond that stuff is an
absoluteness where
what was the first time that what mike
when was the first time that you can
remember
a full day well how old are you when you
could say
today i did the a b and c and then went
to sleep um
how old were you when that happened very
very young earth
i was in a full i was locked up in
captivity
i know my full day i know you know i
know right now when i was younger
that's that's not the only thing that i
know of being um in prison and juvenile
detention centers
i remember those days i can't remember
being free
i don't know what from 12 to what so 12.
so 12 is the you were 12 years old when
you could first
remember a full day yeah how old were
you
how do you i remember
[Music]
being at home the day that my brother
my mom went to the hospital to have my
brother
so you were in three three oh that's but
but
just that moment or the full day you
could i remember the full day of
going to see her at the hospital coming
home
and being with my dad and thinking about
my brother on the way
that's early it's very early it's very
early yeah but you know but it's still
three years old right yeah
it's not like we come into this world
and we can't just we drift into
consciousness right and we drift out of
consciousness
you know and and and there is no real
birth or death you know what i
am at a young age i was really
experienced at a young age i knew what
was happening like i'm saying i'm 10
years old i knew what time it was i
i knew it was like um to hear people
scream in the middle of night
or getting them mugged i hear i saw
people get shot i heard my mother get
[ __ ] a lot
so i knew about the world it wasn't like
i was stupid from the world perspective
i knew what time was i knew not to go
there and nobody careful
talk
something positive well i went to
freelance they fed us
people you didn't connect with anybody
you didn't connect with another human
being you didn't feel the warmth of
another human being or the love or the
friendship or you didn't have
not then not then okay not then no
really
no that is [ __ ] no that's [ __ ] well
i'm sorry that's what it was
i know i'm saying that's that's that's a
lot of that's a lot of
a lot to deal with that's a lot to deal
with i don't know it doesn't seem it's
just like no it's normal to me
so then it just switched off to what and
now and now and now
and now the connectedness and the love
and the sort of the
the relationships with other people that
exists right
it exists yes it exists but i know from
my reality it could be taken away again
very simply i know it could be taken
away
i know it could vanish my experiences of
all those feelings they disappear they
go away
because people leave people die that's
yeah
well abandonment is i think everybody i
mean it's one of my issues for sure
i hate to be left uh you know if my
girlfriend leaves me i'll [ __ ] kill
myself
why would you think that i'm just i'm
just being i'm being facetious you're
not my
we're having a conversation yeah ain't
no time no [ __ ] physician [ __ ]
no you know you know i was j i was
because i was thinking about her and i
was thinking about
what she would do to me if
yeah because she's on my mind she's
praying on my mind she's muslim
and you know that's a very interesting
thing what she taught me is
the one thing that she taught me uh
because she's a biologist and she helped
remove the venom from the toads and we
have cultured these toads
abroad outside of outside of their
homeland in another
in another part of the world and um um
you know the uh this weed is good well
it's the best in the world dude
good brother yeah but listen man it's
just
can you give him the lighter please is
it right here what happened to us he's
right in front of him he's blind
but listen this is just the world i come
from you know the world i come from is
where everybody
is dog eat dog if you if you're the
meanest the biggest the baddest in the
neighborhood you run the neighborhood
[ __ ] the cops we're afraid of him [ __ ]
god we're afraid of him
that's my world fear
but not all fear it can't possibly be
all fear
no that's what i've learned as a child
that's what i learned that's what stuck
with me
you know out of everything in my life
all the love and stuff whatever i
perceived
as 12 years old and moving on only thing
that really stuck
is the fear those guys put in our
neighborhood last night i was driving
through
the angelis forest you know what that is
no okay you know what the angelis forest
is the angelis forest is on the way up
to palmdale
right you go through the angelis voices
where son of sam's killer was
roamed around a lot of people anyway
there's no phone service out there and
you're driving through a very very dark
you know huge huge pieces of land with
nobody around
anyway so i ran out of gas in the
angelis forest it was really like
nighttime last night with no phone no
nothing i didn't have my dog with me
i saw a left i started to project
it being okay i turned left randomly
drove into a town four miles later on
zero gas
and stopped at a gas station and i was
terrified of this place
because it was off the grid and
everybody in there looked like you know
they were on something
but they had very nice cars and they had
horrible homes but very nice cars it was
in the middle of the angelese forest it
was re and off the grid in california
yeah right like an hour away from me
it's an hour away from me so i pulled
over so i pulled over this gas station i
walk into the supermarket to pay for the
gas
and and there are no bars there are no
sort of like strung out people it's like
very nice sort of homey comfort place
and i asked woman dude real place it's
right here it's like an hour's drive
it's like
right near lake hughes why are you
laughing man and
thinking that thinking that i was going
to be murdered and raped
all of a sudden i was in the safest
place on earth why you think somebody
wants to rape you man
because look at me wouldn't you you
think you [ __ ] attracted with
something
look at me yeah i'm looking at you let
me make that statement
i had an experience like that driving
through texas i knew a lot of ugly girls
that gave good head though
well now you see that no but that's a
great
you know that's what life is it's the
unexpected
you know it's the exactly there's two
sides
the mystery of life when we allow that
mystery of life to happen
yeah amazing unimaginable things happen
exactly
like experiencing yeah i had this funny
experience driving through texas that
was similar to that that was a great
uh moment of that realization
i pulled into this gas station in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere
i'm like who liv there's there's not a
town for
25 miles not a not black people don't do
that
[ __ ] in there but there's this shack
with gas that's true
that's some people don't do that that's
true there's too many scary [ __ ]
there wasn't one black person in this
town i'm telling you it was
it was it was it was it was that was a
little scary
interesting yeah that is scary you watch
deliverance and [ __ ] yeah this
this gas station was straight out of the
hills have eyes you remember that movie
they had about four of them i was like
this is the hills have eyes in the back
there's a [ __ ] weird little guy with
[ __ ] kill me my brother's with me i'm
like dude i gotta go
inside to pay for this gas so you just
keep an eye out
you know but anyway i go in there
i get i get a coffee and
um i have to pay for my gas and you
still haven't been shot
i still haven't been killed and the guy
he's just like this
very american texan looking guy
grizzled beard probably smokes two packs
of cigarettes a day
reading a newspaper and
all i have is my credit card and he
left the coffee he's like for the coffee
it's like you know a dollar and he's got
a five dollar minimum on the credit card
and i'm like dude i
i don't have and he's like before and
i'm about to freak out because this
guy's gonna kill me
and he goes oh the coffee's on me man
and i go out get my gas drive off and i
was like
that dude gave me the coffee for free
you know
he thought you were gonna kill him
he was like just so kind so much
kindness in his eyes
were you angry did you go in angry did
you go in a very angry place
and you're and you're quite tall yeah
was he little he was bigger then
i was in the nfl okay i was about 315
pounds
i was recovering from shoulder surgery i
was on a lot of pills into a pissed off
a lot of adderall
driving across country in my bmw [ __ ]
out of my mind dude i'd give you a
[ __ ] coffee farm
yeah but it's just like that unexpected
you know allowing life to unfold before
you sure
you know and you can always be so
brilliantly surprised
well this like right now
i mean we're smoking cannabis
i'm sitting next to mr michael tyson who
i watched wearing those
black shorts of yours and was wondering
like the rest of the world
what this beast is i was trying to
figure that out too
yeah trying to figure that out i mean um
you know for
how do you must be 52 or 53 yeah yeah
because i'm 51 because i remember
i remember watching tv at the time thing
dude that guy's like two years older
than me he's beating the [ __ ] out of all
these guys
amazing you know and amazing amazing
absolutely you were 18 and you were like
taking down
i was just very i had a great teacher a
great teacher
because tomorrow and a great teacher
yeah yeah
he's uh yeah it says this is all this is
all
this is legend right all this stuff is
legend
yeah it's mythology yeah yeah this is
this is uh
uh you know you know memory
this is how we were talking about this
earlier this is how the medicine works
this is how the fiber me or dmt works it
goes back
to the time where we create that belief
in our consciousness that
women are not equal to men
for example right and then
we go through an experience where we go
to that
specific moment in time where that
memory becomes a core belief in our
psyche
and it repeats itself over and over and
over and over again
in infinitesimal uh you know you know
uh uh an infinitesimal number of times
and all in an instance and that moment
is erased and it goes back to
our to to the divine's concept of our
absolute state
and and that's where the healing happens
in erasing
the beliefs that uh contradict
the will of the divine and that's as far
as i can [ __ ] take it
i think that's a great description of
that process i've done ayahuasca
dmt i know a lot about the toad i
haven't done the toad i even
felt specifically called to the toad but
it's been
very interesting watching mike on his
journey with it
and that's what my understanding of all
of these plant medicines
and the journey of life it's just
expedites that pathway
to erasing that trauma coming to terms
with
our pain in our trauma
yeah you know um
pain is optional i learned that a long
time ago and i never
really understood it but pain really is
optional
if i get aids from having unprotect
unprotected protected sex right
i have no one else to blame
for that path for me getting aids than
me
right that's just that's
absolutely right that's a that so that's
that's extreme that but
but but man but
no but but my whole consciousness is
built on that basis
right so everything that i bring into my
life
i option right so every time
you go to jail yeah i went to jail for
the first time in my life recently for
one night
why what happened i was arrested with 5
000 cannabis plants
what was that about well i was the
specialist
it is a special it's not cannabis it's
actually it's actually genus swiss x
which is the name of the company
uh we we we have a genetics company but
we also produce uh
you know we also produce you know
illegal cannabis uh
cannabinoid products like cbd products
and we manufacture them in switzerland
and
and the swiss x brand is a strong
leading red bull for cannabis type of
brand right it's it
we we um we promote extreme sports and
uh
lifestyle uh in in a healing lifestyle
from an extreme sports perspective
is it really made in switz yeah it's
made in the village of xtad
and where we we're in a in a building
that is the oh it was built in 1740 the
building it's an old
old wooden building and uh underneath
underground is the um
extraction facility and the packaging
plant what makes you happy
uh happy you mean you mean not in pain
no um what is it um
ma what makes me happy transcendent i i
i don't pursue happiness no no oh that's
interesting talk about that i like to
hear this one
you know i for me my
my pain comes in only comes when i
engage in pain for example if i engage
into an argument with my girlfriend over
something
inane right and i
get aggravated and we want to kill each
other we want to separate and leave and
end it and it's a horrible horrible
horrible experience for us all this
evening
um you know if i want to engage in that
i can and i can opt for the pain
but if i can [ __ ] remember to just
take a step back and maybe even force
myself to run away like a crazy person
and just go bolt and when i come back
guess what it's gonna be completely
different it's cool
yeah you know 99 of the [ __ ] that i
worry about every day will never [ __ ]
happen
yeah it will never happen and you didn't
involve yourself in the chaos
yeah of that moment and create more you
know
listen if you're addicted to chaos
that's a serious drug dude it's like
that so that that
it's like that age-old expression that
we came up in the conversation earlier i
could have been a great man
if it hadn't been for me [ __ ] i know
that feeling
my dick [ __ ] me up i should have cut
my dick off my whole life would have
been different did all the great things
that happened
have cut my [ __ ] dick i would be
[ __ ] president of the [ __ ] country
you would have been the first cross
gender self
self self self diagnosed and self
rather than that self reconstructed
self self crossed up about that
it's amazing you know how we choose to
alter our skin bags nowadays it's
incredible
and we can actually it's how many videos
have you seen of gorgeous girls that
suddenly dicks pop out of nowhere
you know i mean how many of those videos
have you watched today not many
really yeah all right but that's cool
you know i mean
i mean if you're yeah you have no
judgments on that
what are you saying yeah well there's
guys out here that's all good there's
guys out here that are beautiful and
have any girl they want
any any money they have and have
anything and they're miserable in a few
minutes they're going to kill that
[ __ ] self
what about those guys they need to they
need to chill
why you know they um this world to find
happiness is having everything
i have everything with [ __ ] i don't i'm
still doing that no no i'm saying i'm
saying if
if if somebody is miserable and wants to
stop being miserable
a lot of people feel that way but you
know you know you know you never felt
that way you talked about killing
yourself over your girlfriend you never
felt that
no one time
one time one time in my life it changes
everything yeah you said whoa yeah yeah
you think oh
if i'm gonna go down that road then
actually you know what i'm not going
down that road thank you very much
because
my survival is too strong in me yeah
yeah
and and and and so if i'm not going to
go down that road then i have no option
then to take another [ __ ] road
because i'm not going down there again
so why do you think well listen to your
brightness why do you think we feel that
way you're thinking
i think it comes from our shame what
kind of shame we possess that wants us
to want to die oh i can't take it i
don't want nobody to know
[ __ ] me you you are your father you are
your father's son
yeah i think so yeah and and he is his
father's son
right and he and all those men bring
brought to you who you are today and all
those women brought to you who you are
today
and in another and in another dimension
i think all those people took away what
i could have been
that is really a lot of self-fucking
pity
nah i know yeah that's something
i used to blame my father i used to
blame my father but you told me
i found my father's son i'm on fire i'm
all in my general basically
who they were are in you and ultimately
ultimately we all come from one
ultimately we all come
scientifically and mystically
we both come from one all right so but
if i came from all those people and they
and they
and they directed this kind of energy
towards me and i become this kind of
person
so these are the answers i would have
the right to have some kind of self-hate
i might not want to be the way i am but
i can't stop it but you've evolved to a
different person than you were when you
were 18 right or when you were 16 or 15
yeah
right so that that person that was born
was all those people bundled into
one and then you had to figure out in
your experience whatever your experience
is and this is what this plant medicine
does this very
all plant medicines do is go to the
pineal gland which is where der scout
the
17th century and make you question dr
matteson talked about being the seat of
the soul that generates
sin it also generates the dna that
lives in our body is created here in the
in in the paneers
and that is where the plant medicine
works it works in clearing
that genetic encoding that your father's
father handed on to you
and made you who you are and who you opt
to be today who you choose to be today
based on the tools that you're given in
your in your in your mind
all right so right now i'm who my
parents i'm who my parents put suppose i
switch right now so i want to be a
scumbag i don't want to be this brother
no more
what would happen well you are thank you
you are who you are right
you you are what you are whatever you
are you are that thing and you're not
getting away from it i'm not getting
away from what i
am you know i i exist in me as
me and nowadays i'm
really really enjoying my experience
most of the time in my
in my most of the time i'm enjoying my
experience
and really enjoying my experience in
sofacto
i enjoy the good and the bad you know i
enjoy the i enjoy the i enjoy the sort
of the difficult
and the not so difficult in people you
know i enjoy the sort of the challenging
not so challenging
in things and that's a very different
place because before it was like
it was a pain in the ass and [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] this
so what do we want to do who do we want
to become there's a noise impact wow
who do we want to become what is the
blueprint of becoming
the thing that we should become i think
that that's just a very
abstract idea of a of a trick
that we need to perform because all we
do is tricks right
all we do is tricks that's all we do
tricks
that's what we do as as as conscious
creatures whatever the [ __ ]
this thing is do you seem like how do we
all live as one then
we are we are and it's getting better
and the experience is getting better
yeah the experience is definitely
the world health organization is
demanding that
south [ __ ] korea gives out marijuana
licenses
that is great that's a big time that's
greatness
big the the the farm bill
is in effect you think they're getting
that is great what do you think
they get tour with them huh
yeah once they open up cannabis tourism
no they're just going to get people
better yeah
yeah it's going to help a lot of people
yeah people
the experience is going to be better you
know we're going to live a more
heightened
aware aware experience of our
consciousness that isn't necessarily the
one that
we're pre-conditioned to believe in
through our
predisposition of our dna encoding and
this and the and the environments that
we grow up in
well it's really
what you guys are both talking about is
you know there's a there's the divine
self
within all of us that is constantly
unfolding
whether we want it to or not and really
our job in this
life is to just get out of the way of
that so that that can happen
you want to know what i find really
amazing tell us
is the darkness you know the empty space
that exists between us
right isn't empty it's filled
with magnetic and and
and where and what and bra and
dimensions
and dimensions of reality and dimensions
of consciousness and things that
we can't see but we do see when we close
our eye and we
you know every religion has the middle
eye has the third eye or the where the
pineal gland sits which is you know
the evil eye or the hamza or the or the
first eye
or the first eye right it's all it all
sits in this place
and when we close our eyes we connect
with and so
those experiences that you had of seeing
the universe and being the universe
did you have that experience do you have
that feeling i think dimensions
right i was over yeah at one one time i
did around five times so one time i did
it i'm over the universe i'm looking at
the planet
and we all and the [ __ ] up thing right
is that we all
see the same thing yeah
at different times i guess right no but
but i did it five times and every time i
did that
different we all have a different
combination or we all have a different
way of everything is you know my my
fingerprints are different this is your
puzzle my you know we have different
fingerprints right
um we'll we'll go we'll different
perspectives
of the same baby
oh you're a sick [ __ ] elk it's great to
have you here brother
tell us about getting stopped that's not
me coughing by the way
that's big bad mike coughing down like i
was feeling it
giant feline mike felt the hit
tell us what it was like getting caught
with the plants in your plane
yeah here's the amazing thing so you're
on this caribbean island of seventy
thousand it's two islands
nevisons and kits the same island
whether play hamilton is based on
the same guy who started wall street
hamilton right so my lawyer actually
ended up being this rastafarian black
dude
hamilton hamilton was the mulatto huh
hamilton with the mulatto right so my
lawyer
my lawyer is a hamilton and he's a
director
you know wow and but so so my experience
was
i never felt unsafe i always the people
are
wholesome islanders generally around the
world wherever you're on an island
people are very
wholesome right yeah and and and the law
is british law that's been adapted for
the kittitian
law uh but it's still the same thing but
the irony is is that it's
uh it's uh uh
people running a system that is based on
suppressing a system that these people
are indigenous and spiritually attuned
to
in other words uh this this statistic of
70 percent of the nation of sin kits are
going to go to jail like every every
caribbean nation
every afro-caribbean nation the
the the inhabitants will go to jail 70
of the nation will go to jail on a
cannabis charge and they still
all live in old draconian british legal
systemization on
of cannabis which is kind of messed up
but with genetics we're now starting to
move those posts because
we are no longer on the cornerstone of
this law which is genus cannabis
if we can move from genus swiss x or
genus something else
we move we're able to change the law and
move move in time with
in a time where those laws were written
where genetics were not taken into
account for
now you wouldn't think an island would
be um
marijuana illegal right i know well
somehow some are in some aren't like
antigua just passed the law last year
that legalized it
what's jamaica's status jamaica is
full-on full of
let's go dispensaries or shops
cafes you could just go in do they have
like smells i shut the sheriff good move
on
yeah oh god that's a good way to be
man it's a good lifestyle it is i mean
jamaica
jamaica have embraced it and guess what
they are
they are they are doing uh they're
making things
really really happen for their economy
you know both for their economy as well
as the well-being of the people
yeah because now guess what you know i
didn't smoke weed for 20 years
i didn't why not because uh i had a
drinking and
either drinking more i had a problem
with weed
why but guess what it wasn't the problem
it was
people telling me i had a problem and me
believing it
you know and and uh and me following
you know guided principles of existence
to not
and then i understood that well hold on
a second
i'm actually not genetically [ __ ] up
or maybe i am genetically [ __ ] up
maybe i'm not well let me take this so i
took and guess what i am genetic i was
genetically
i'm now genetically better my the
genetics
in me which are harmonized by my dna
frequencies
have changed because of the medicine
they've actually
changed physically atomically changed
the medicine you you speak of is the
toad i speak of all plant medicine i
speak i speak of all natural medicines
biomedicine not just plant medicine by
because toad is a biomedicine it's not a
plant it's a yes
it's a it's it's it's a good word i've
i've been wondering what
i know that because it's not you're
right it's not a plant
obviously it's exciting it's a naturally
existing compound
and there are others but all compounds
are natural even
even synthetic stuff is natural right
why do you think
um a species human being why do you
think we we get high
because highness is the ultimate state
of consciousness
you know we are high why do we call it
high because we are high
i'm gonna start loving you [ __ ] stop
talking [ __ ] i'm feeling good in here
right you'll be the highest [ __ ]
state
you know i mean and you know what what
was amazing was uh being in some kids
and i
ran out of my indica and my one puff and
your [ __ ] to death weed that we buy now
um and i was smoking the the local
rastafari the king of the rastafari
gave me his thing because we were giving
them seeds and we were giving and that's
the pla that's the seed program we're
running in the in the in the caribbean
islands is sort of giving uh
giving seeds in exchange for harvest
mm-hmm and uh and uh
and uh you know helping the old cocoa
farm the old um
coffee and the old sugarcane farms we
adapt
but um uh i got this weed
and it was a totally different
experience because it's not like blowing
my brains out
right it's playing with my spirit right
here
right between my eyes and it's playing
and it's get and it's
really truly a different thing it's a
different high
it's still a high we're still connecting
out we're we're dissolving our ego when
we get why we dissolve our ego self we
dissolve our understanding of ourselves
when a smack addict takes smack and they
get and they drift off you know
they drift off the ego itself disappears
and to say that that is a bad thing
well you know when you see when you see
that's what we does when you smoke a lot
of when you hide until you start
touching your
[Music]
that's what you do you're friendly well
what about if the if the substance
takes more from you than it gives
and that's bad and bad stuff
oh you believe that now do you i think
with heroin listen there are
there are there are 150 official
unanswered questions in science 150
do you think hold on hold on hold on
okay there are 150 unanswered questions
in science
oh really that's uh no no no they're
actually scientists will say there are
thousands
or millions even or or infinite numbers
yeah of unanswered questions but the
point is
is is that anybody who claims like you
said at the beginning of all this
conversation was that we know nothing
you know we know we and and and it's an
absolute state the scary thing is about
this 500 dmt is that when it brings you
to the absolute state of absolute
aloneness
and that god woke up one day and was
bored and created himself
and and then replicated and then we're
all little pieces of god pointing out at
each other and now
consciousness is a fun game the
rastafari i believe that consciousness
is reality and reality is consciousness
and that it is all glued together by the
divine glue
the the glue of the divine of the divine
and that makes sense
but if you're taking
a shitload of opiates or pills something
that's destroying you
physically and sure maybe it dissolves
the ego for a moment
who are you even who are you talking
about i'm talking about
the thousands of people dying from
opiate addictions
but who specifically are you talking
about are you talking about yourself
um are you talking about my experience
with
or you talk about your fears of yourself
and dying of that because you don't give
a [ __ ] about anybody else dying from
opium
i mean i don't do you i'm afraid of
myself
except myself except myself really do
you give a [ __ ] about anybody else dying
from opium ultimately
i don't want them to die but if they die
there's nothing like that
okay so i mean i'm going to die yeah
we're all going to die
i mean really die we're actually going
to understand
or do we or do we die or do i really die
i mean i mean the thing is i believe
whatever whatever whatever
whatever created mic um you know
whatever mic is cannot be created and
can't be destroyed
right and whatever you are whatever i am
whatever anybody else in here is can't
be created or be destroyed it just can't
be
it's not something that we can
understand its creation or its
destruction
yes i i'm i totally agree with that
i agree with all of you so
when you have now that we've agreed yes
we can now exist in the understanding
that it's all going to be okay i believe
i believe i believe what we believe as
god
what it is okay i believe whatever we
think and believe is god is real
[ __ ] inconceivable to us so then i do
have a complaint
whoever invented time is a dick
time that time has been invented as well
time don't [ __ ] exist when i took the
toad i didn't i was in time and space it
was no time no space
i saw my whole life go in front of me
and then when my life was over boom
i was still there now what
you know now what what's gonna happen
now i can't see myself i feel the energy
and what i'm gonna do now and that is
the have you seen
uh uh android jones
have you seen his look look look look up
on youtube android jones
if you're not familiar with the work of
and look up android jones
ayahuasca art this guy this guy's oh yes
i know this guy's
he's an incredible incredible
when you see it you'll understand it
mike because what he's going to do is
that he visually
visually captures a lot of the
experience
but he's blind did you know that
i did not know that now you do
or he's partially blind well guess what
what
there's a guy with no brain look at look
it up google the man with no brain there
is a guy
ninety percent gone ninety percent blown
up
he's an accountant he has a family and
he has a he has a low iq but he exists
as
a so go to youtube and play one of these
videos they're absolutely extraordinary
and and and when you see it mike guy
with no brain
man with no brain man man man man man
he's a man with no brain man with no
brain not work
with we've got a second
now now go to go to news or go to all go
to audiences
but you see you see that brain that that
guy is a normal
functioning look at that meet the man
who lives normally with damage
to 90 percent of his brain not damage
it's actually non-existence
and so oh so in um that looks like an
ass
no it's a brain sorry it's a very
[ __ ] hamburger meat
or a very old ass
yeah you think they're looking at the
ass old ass they all wrinkled
what after you've been looking at me i
haven't been looking at any i'm just how
does that look like an ass
so how do you know how do you know well
i know the answers i've seen that would
look like that brain
clever so this guy with no brain
functions
so it's consciousness without no without
a physical
yes so so so what this says so this is a
robot
no he no he has a family he has a job as
a
as a as an accountant and he has a low i
relatively low how you can be an
accountant and have a low iq
but he lives in argentina so maybe that
that shows why the economy is what it is
yeah and and and the the but the the
point is
is that this man has a normal
functioning life and he has
virtually zero brain the point being
that the mind operates outside of the
brain
right and that is a fine example of it
and there are many examples like this
with
encephalitis and and microcephalus and
all of these illnesses that destroy the
brain
people do actually continue to live
normal
you know fully healthy lives
and and and and you know uh people who
are at death's door
and are on uh you know uh you know end
of life
people that survived executions
yes those are those are the good ones
that got shot at front pump
range like french soldier and he didn't
die got bullet in the head
six people who survived their own
executions yeah
and we should be in history the people
in history that's about
saddam hussein didn't survive no way
that was
that that was [ __ ] [ __ ] up some guys
they hung guys sometimes
they were so fat the head just came
right off because the body was so happy
boom pop the head right off i started
that's crazy this is yes
whatsapp group called group f that i
started we get all the latest videos all
the
beheadings and mass executions you get
everything
you know um you know because you know it
sort of really gives
a sort of a real understanding to
to the scope of my existence
you know i mean i don't have i've never
been arrested right i've never had
handcuffs in my life i had all this
experience in a sort of in a safe
environment
um uh but that whole world that mike
talks about that's a completely [ __ ]
different thing to
the only time i've ever been to jail
other than that was to do a talk on
drugs
what a [ __ ] idiot i was you know i
sat in a room with ten
serial killers and they were working
yeah and they were all under the age of
18 and they're all serial killers it was
really probably looked like a wrist
a rare steak to them you know what i
mean
look at the imagine what i could dissect
on him
thank you don't look at me
like that anymore stop don't look at me
like that
licking those lips oh cool i've seen
people pass away well who are the people
that died
okay let's see the man
the man frank 1872 copied the murder
recorded as the man frank okay
australian paper survived his execution
thanks to his executioner's great
incompetence he also had the unfortunate
destruction
of being the first person to be executed
briefly what happened i haven't
instagrammed any of this
[ __ ] i can't believe it wait you know
don't live stream too much well no i'm
gonna just do a couple of clips
is that right it's okay you can do a few
little clips do you not normally do this
we don't do live streaming no no no no
no what
hello everyone evan britton here coming
to you live
nobody nobody cares all anybody wants is
this i'm in your [ __ ] house
right now [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
right now that's so mean
be quiet nobody cares heaven everyone
wants to know about this
do you do you really think anybody would
care
that's my culture that's my car defender
i care that's my crime we're crime mates
mike cares mike but yeah
thank you beautiful stuff i love this
place this guy you're awesome man
you're a lot of fun
is this cbd no no
you've got to hear this man this man why
are you walking with a walking stick
again i thought you got rid of this is
your swiss sex
no no no he's not he's actually not he
just happens to wear a swiss x
t-shirt but yeah but he's actually he's
actually a client of swiss x
oh sweet what happened man what's up
dude i met alfie david about two weeks
ago
two weeks two weeks ago yes what did you
think about it when you first met aoki
oh man cbd man he came right up to me
and asked what was wrong with my knee
out of cane
i dislocated my knee uh commercial crab
fishing uh out of bodega bay you didn't
think he was a weird [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you care about my knee [ __ ]
well all right he actually i gave him
some of my
my product here and uh he came right to
me and gave me some cbd
it was honey this uh i think i brought
it in i didn't call you honey
you didn't call me honey no but uh i
took uh he gave me a dose of this within
15 minutes of taking the pure cbd my
knee i swear to god loosened up i had no
pain in my knee
and i was walking without the mouth
right under the tongue yeah
we have a new thing called the golden
bullet and the golden bullet is 67
percent
uh pure pure uh um uh you know
um but it's um this you know it's uh
distilled it's a
it's a distillate uh not an isolate it's
a full spectrum
uh uh cbd cbd flower that we grow in
switzerland
and it's a 67 pure oil uh it's a one
gram
but extremely powerful so anyone that
takes that gets a real
full on you really shouldn't be taking
how many tattoos you got you got cool
tattoos man
they are my many wives
i took a dose of this golden bullet uh
two weeks ago with a friend of mine i
took it back to
santa rosa where i live and i came to a
point of
consciousness of just straight focus
you got the golden bullet here where's
the golden bullet well we don't have it
he's going to be our friends
this is a lighter version i'll bring
this i'll say this is the sex one this
has everything
this has epi media do you have a problem
getting it up
sometimes well this will be a wonderful
wonderful relaxing solution
oh my wife's gonna love you that's
perfect excellent
right no no that's not true
oh [ __ ] off
why are you saying no that's not true he
said my his wife is going to love me
yeah yeah i don't know he's going to be
able to say this thanks brother what
this works right in my country in my
country if you say that
if you say that you you you you get
can't be insecure you have to trust
there's trust in the family
it's all about trusting it is it is how
many children have you got
seven trust in love how many children
seven seven i'm boys girls
um three boys and uh you went to three
boys and four girls i got four boys
four boys and one step daughter god
bless them
and you you don't want a daughter oh you
do yes
seven year okay that's good man
yeah and you're you're involved with uh
coca-cola
um i i'm my my lady
take a coke and smile [ __ ]
say that again take a coke and smile
[ __ ] right
yeah wait can i record that because
that's a new slogan
have you seen those youtube videos of
the kids who like go to cross the
borders and they
say they freak out i've got coke in the
background they're they're recording
with the hidden cameras and everybody's
freaking out those are
those are amazing videos yeah it's
awesome man
yeah well [ __ ] hey dude thank you for
coming in
my pleasure listening it's a lot of fun
are you kicking me out now no brother i
just want you to know i want to show you
around man this is an awesome place
i want to see what we doing we got to
build um like
what we have a 400 acre ow why the [ __ ]
did you do that
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] is wrong
you're a psycho you're a [ __ ] psycho
this is the new thing this is the new
thing
yeah you've been on before when you got
you're on medicine
aren't you dude i i listen i told you i
did
i did five more dmt several times a day
for six months every day
now how do you feel [ __ ] man that's
[ __ ] a rush
i tell you every day you know they're in
labs now i'm working i've worked with a
guy called dr joseph barcuglio who works
at ucla
working with fiverr me or dmt and the
treatment of alzheimer's
and are we not supposed to plug no talk
any kind of [ __ ]
anyway anyway anyway so so so so listen
so joseph has been developing
uh synthetic fibromyalgia dmt and now
they're adding other tryptamines that is
naturally in the uh in the uh you know
in the oil that comes from the toad
uh it's not venom it's oil it really
it's defensive oil
uh uh and um and they're they're
building it
scientifically so it's going to be much
much cheaper because this is a very rare
animal and
it's it's it's it's um
it's uh it's got to be built in the lab
and uh and this is going to be like the
greatest cure for humanity
uh in the future and not too distant
because you can see in the movement of
the world the world is
radically changing we are changing as a
species
the world over you know the way we eat
food is different now
you know people are conscious of what
they put in their stomach now and
you know you just put [ __ ] in them and
we're very conscious of sugar
and all that small furry animals that
are still alive
yeah yeah i agree with that too
no animals don't knock it till you try
it
no way dude i'm a vegan i am a vegan
vegan you are respectful actually i eat
cheese and eggs
i do eat cheese vegetarian uh yeah well
faken i call myself faker yeah i don't
eat meat
chicken fish or anything i do i i avoid
shellfish i can't eat shellfish i don't
not that i can't i just don't want to
uh because it just for me i
but i love i love to see other people
eat other
other other um conscious creatures you'd
love to yeah
well i mean it makes me feel better
about myself like you're doing something
you feel conceited yeah yeah that's cool
consider considering it's an interesting
perspective what
conceit tell me about that conceit is
like
self no it's the most sort of
it's it's sort of uh tricking myself
into believing that
i'm totally cool and everything is right
and i'm correct and
i don't have to worry about anything i
think you are totally cool
well yes in my head and if i can remain
like that
you know what was what was interesting
recently uh you know
being you know challenging challenging
conditions and finding going straight to
the happy place
as opposed to the straight to the
fighting place well
that's
that isn't always the same buddha is it
it's not the same
but mostly it's a lot better right it's
a lot better it's a lot
and it'll continue to get better with
more application
and it will actually continue to get
better with more application
but it needs to be done in a healthy you
know because for me
i've been my own guinea pig and the
guinea pig of friends close to me
because what you know the experience
that i've had
really has helped um give a lot of data
about what this thing does and
it is a very very safe medicine
it's extremely safe there are no deaths
i did two times one day and go for it
our self-identity our attachment our
conscious awareness to this
thing of of ourself will always bring us
back to
our version of reality that we've
learned to understand since birth you
know
but it takes you on a journey buddy
whoa you're like [ __ ] right yeah it
takes
you know the euphemism of the toad takes
you is absolutely correct
it's like um you know what it is it's um
a hundred if you struggle if you
struggle
you'll be terrified it's like you'll
have a terrible experience it's 1500
yeah but you're going to have the
experience anyway right it's coming
and the toad doesn't give a [ __ ] you
know it's going to take
and and the and and it is the most
beautiful the most sublime the most
terrifying you
you die you're reborn there's several
times over in one
experience that lasts you know a few
minutes
and uh and and time is not relative
in this experience time is beyond time
don't exist yeah
it doesn't exist space and time don't
exist
because you think you're under there for
10 hours and you come out you only do 20
minutes
you think it's never going to end
and now we will all explode hey let's
get the [ __ ] out of here hey guys hey
everybody
this is a great episode of hot boxing
thank you brother for coming here
what a lot of fun i had a good time me
too
vader's beautiful yeah and oh and and i
was late
i was late and i apologize for being
later because i ended up in a place
called el segundo there's another el
segundo
about 20 20 miles away from here it's a
[ __ ]
it's like there are you can die there do
you know what i'm talking about
and i was like [ __ ] mike's really
downgraded yeah
it was like i was right it was terrible
this place i come and then i was
so thankful that there was another el
segundo was it in the middle of the
angelus forest
no this is in the middle of the deepest
darkest baddest compton
oh yes yeah oh compton's not bad at some
of these places yeah the other
crunch boulevard crenshaw the other
elsagon that one yeah
where is that it's somewhere where
you're talking compton
yeah you got nice shoes on man really
cool shoes
thank you dope outfit brother oh well i
just i got out of bed
here's my slippers awesome man thank you
that was a lot of fun mike hey this is
another awesome episode of hot boxing
i'm mike tyson
i'm evan i'm out of here guys see ya
we're out
peace
[Music]
bye